>>> ABRAHAM LINCOLN SMILED.
SHE MAY BE FLAWED BUT SHE'S
STILL MY COUNTRY.
ANYWAY, SEE YOU TONIGHT.
AT THE THEATER.
THE END.
>> WOW.
THAT WAS GREAT, LINUS.
AND VERY RELEVANT, TOO.
>> VERY MUCH THE INTENTION.
THANK YOU.
>> WELL, WELL, GREAT STORIES
TONIGHT, EVERYONE.
AND WE WILL BE BACK NEXT MONTH,
ALL ARE WELCOME.
SIR, I'M SORRY.
WE'LL BE TWO MINUTES.
>> OH, MY GOSH.
YOU'RE NOT FINISHED.
EXCUSE ME.
>> WELL, ACTUALLY, SIR -- I
DON'T THINK WE'VE EVER ACTUALLY
SPOKEN.
BUT I FEEL LIKE I ALWAYS SEE YOU
WITH A DIFFERENT BOOK.
YOU LIKE READING?
>> OH, YEAH.
YES, MA'AM.
IT'S HOW I'VE SEEN THE WORLD TEN
TIMES OVER, BECAUSE OF MY BOOKS.
>> I LOVE THAT.
YOU EVER TRY ANY WRITING?
>> I MEAN, I DABBLE.
BUT NO, MAYBE ONE DAY.
YOU ALL ARE THE WRITERS.
>> WELL, WHY DON'T YOU READ US
SOMETHING?
WHATEVER YOU GOT.
>> OH, I DON'T KNOW.
>> HEY, HEY.
NO JUDGMENTS HERE.
WE'RE ALL JUST TRYING STUFF OUT.
PROMISE.
>> COME ON, MAN, TAKE A SEAT.
>> YEAH, I'D LOVE TO HEAR IT,
PAL.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> GOSH, THAT'S SO NICE.
I'VE NEVER READ IN FRONT OF
PEOPLE BEFORE.
THIS ONE'S CALLED "THE APOGEE OF
MIDNIGHT."
>> OH, LOVELY.
PLEASE.
>> OKAY.
THERE IT WAS AGAIN.
THE SOUND OF MOP ON TILE.
THE START OF ANOTHER LATE NIGHT.
ONE OF THOUSANDS LIKE IT.
ALONE IN CHANDLER HIGH.
BUT THE JANITOR LIKED THE
SILENCE.
IT HELD HIM IN A COOL, DELICATE
CALM.
>> HM, WOW, I REALLY LIKE THAT.
>> THANK YOU.
THEN, FOOTSTEPS.
LOUD AND GETTING CLOSER.
HELLO?
SCHOOL'S CLOSED.
A WOMAN TURNED THE CORNER.
SHE LOOKED LOST.
SORRY, I'M LOOKING FOR SOMEONE
NAMED MIKE?
OH, YEAH?
WHO'S ASKING?
MY NAME IS DUA LIPA.
I'M A BIG POP STAR AND I'M
LOOKING FOR A JANITOR NAMED
MIKE.
>> OKAY.
>> THE JANITOR PAUSED.
THAT WAS HIS NAME.
DUA LIPA SIGHED.
YOU HAVEN'T HEARD OF ME, HAVE
YOU?
SORRY, MA'AM.
MORE OF A CLASSIC ROCK GUY
MYSELF.
BUT SURE, MAYBE I'VE SEEN A
BIKINI PIC OR TWO, HOW CAN I
HELP?
>> OKAY, YOU KNOW WHAT, IT IS
GETTING PRETTY LATE.
SO I THINK WE SHOULD PROBABLY
WRAP IT UP.
>> WHAT?
HE JUST STARTED.
>> WRAP UP?
SO I CAN MOP?
HECK, I GOT TIME.
>> YEAH, AND I WANT TO KNOW
WHERE IT'S GOING.
>> I DON'T.
>> YEAH, I THINK I'M GOOD.
>> YEAH, YOU'RE RIGHT.
I'M BAD AT THIS.
>> NO, NO.
WE SUPPORT IT.
SO PLEASE, GO AHEAD.
>> OH, THANK YOU.
MIND IF I SIT DOWN?
DUA LIPA WAS EXHAUSTED.
SHE'D JUST DONE A CONCERT IN
EUROPE.
AND WAS STILL IN HER SPARKLY
SHOW GETUP.
HE LIKED HER.
SHE WAS COOL.
SO WHAT BRINGS YOU OUT ALL THIS
WAY TO SEE LITTLE OLD ME,
GIRLIE?
OH, I DON'T KNOW, THIS IS GOING
TO SOUND CRAZY.
COME ON, DUA LIPA, YOU KNOW YOU
CAN TALK TO ME.
I'M YOUR FRIEND.
IT'S TRUE.
THEY WERE FAST FRIENDS.
AND NOTHING MORE.
RIGHT?
>> ARE YOU ASKING US?
>> PLEASE.
I'M STILL READING.
WELL, I GUESS I WANTED TO ASK
YOU A FAVOR, MIKE.
SURE THING, GIRLIE.
WHAT'S UP?
WOULD YOU TEACH ME HOW TO MAKE
OUT?
I'VE NEVER DONE IT BEFORE.
>> OKAY, I'M SORRY, I JUST --
NO.
>> OH, COME ON.
>> WHY?
>> LOOK, I THINK THAT IT'S GREAT
THAT YOU WRITE.
I JUST DON'T REALLY WANT TO
HEAR ABOUT YOUR WEIRD, MADE-UP
THING WITH DUA LIPA.
I'M SORRY, I DON'T.
>> MY THING?
THIS AIN'T ME, MAMA, THIS IS
FICTION.
THIRD PERSON.
>> YEAH, ABOUT A JANITOR NAMED
MIKE.
>> RIGHT.
>> AND SO WHAT IS YOUR NAME?
>> MICHAEL B. JACKSON.
WHY?
>> IT'S KIND OF CREEPY, MAN.
>> VERY CREEPY.
>> I SEE.
I GUESS I'M NOT A WRITER AFTER
ALL.
BACK TO THE TOILETS IT IS.
>> JUST FINISH IT, PLEASE.
>> OKAY, COOL.
OKAY.
SURE, DUA LIPA, I CAN TEACH YOU
HOW TO MAKE OUT.
WAIT, CAN MY FRIEND COME?
HER NAME IS TAWNY McDANIELS.
THE FAMOUS GINGER MILF?
ONE AND THE SAME.
YOU KNOW HER?
KNOW HER?
I MANAGE HER SUB BRAND.
OF COURSE PORNOGRAPHY HASN'T
BEEN THE SAME SINCE THE '70s.
THAT'S BEFORE T.J. MUNST TOOK
OVER AT STUFFED.
WHEN THE MAGS HAD VISION AND THE
SPREADS WERE ACTUALLY GOOD.
>> SORRY, I DO THINK WE NEED TO
CALL IT THERE.
I'M SORRY.
>> OKAY, OKAY, OKAY.
STUFF HAPPENS, STUFF HAPPENS,
SO, DUA LAUGHED.
HA HA HA!
HEY, MICHAEL B., THANKS.
THIS TRULY WAS THE APOGEE OF
MIDNIGHT.
AMEN.
CHAPTER 2.
>> AMEN?
>> CHAPTER 2?
THAT WASN'T THE END?
>> OH, HONEY, WE GOT 800 PAGES
IN BOOK ONE, STRAP IN.
>> HAVE A GREAT NIGHT, EVERYONE.
GET HOME SAFE.
OKAY?
>> ALL RIGHT.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]